I am Mike Gallup I am the chief
operating officer of the Portland
Timbers the Portland Timbers are now in
our third year of Major League Soccer
we've really taken the city and the
league by storm Portland has long been
referred to as soccer City USA because
people even green soccer in the city
passionate avid crazy wacky devoted
engaged fans I've ever been around in
sports
sounds like hyperbole but it isn't there
are nuts
one of those why just love sports in
general is there very few places in
contemporary society where you can come
and regardless of your age your gender
your ethnicity your socioeconomic status
you have this shared experience
it's not everyday you get a chance to
start a sports team come scratch we were
able to sit down and say you know what
should we be that we really wanted to be
authentic to the game authentic to our
city think of ourselves as sort of the
people's team accessible down-to-earth
fun and I think we clearly have achieved
that
tonight we'll have people on their feet
all game singing and chanting and
dancing and creating an environment that
is unique we have been one of the most
successful pro sports expansion launches
in history we are the high point to date
for a major league soccer team in terms
of sponsorship the thing that fans would
notice isn't any of that but is really
the atmosphere here is second to none
it's little bits of all the great soccer
cultures mixed in a bowl and it turns
out to be something that's decidedly
Portland and it's a special experience
Sports is an interesting business we
would choose to support us and buy
tickets and wear their gear not from
here but from here you don't buy your
cable because you love the cable company
you buy your cable because I've got to
have cable support a sports team because
the grab sense who you are I grab sense
of city makes you proud I knew I wanted
to be in the sports industry and it's
lucky enough to get into Stanford
graduate school business I don't use
microeconomics in daily basis running a
sports team but it taught me how to
think better how to manage better how to
be more self-aware just be more
strategic Mike Gallup is face and I
think something of the heart of this
team you come to a game here
Mike Gallup is working the stands he's
the front-of-the-house guy which is why
they've been very successful here I used
to work for a David Stern the
Commissioner of the NBA it needs to say
Mike you got to be more of an [ __ ]
you got to be harder on people you can
be more an [ __ ] and I said David you
know it's not me I I think I can get
people's respect and get things done and
effective way without being in a table
and being mean to people that was an
interesting lesson I think the skills I
learned in Business School gave me the
security and comfort to be able to
manage my career and my day-to-day
interactions in a way that's consistent
with who I am as a person if you're a
young person and I'm a genuine interest
in getting in sports where there aren't
very many jobs you have to take it as
seriously as pre-med students take the
medical profession so many people have
encountered abandon the hope and go on
to a more traditional round there's
nothing wrong with that but don't don't
give up stay true to your original
objectives that that sent you to
business school in the first place
if you're really committed there'll be
opportunities it's not life and death is
sports but we're bringing people
together and we're giving back and we're
uniting people and we're creating fun
and making people proud of it steam in
the city and that's why I love this
business
this last few years with Timbers have
been enormous to fund as I think we've
achieved that sort of connection a team
and town community and city and club and
it's been really fun